the question is does your why change in
time the answer is no it does not we all
only have one why are why is fully
formed probably in our late teens
something like that you know the rest of
our lives offer us opportunities to live
in balance with that why or not now the
language can evolve for sure but the
basic idea the basic sentiment of what
the why is is permanent it is basically
an origin story that's what a why is why
is the sum total of who we are based on
how we were raised experiences we had
there's kids just like the wife and
organization is also basically an origin
story it's way the organization comes
from it's based on the problem that the
founders were trying to solve or the
opportunity they were trying to grasp
whatever it is so your Y is fixed your Y
it's permanent the language can evolve
but you are who you are we are who we
all are